>>> WAIT TILL YOU WATCH THIS, A
LIBERAL WRESTLER FROM
APPALACHIA, I USE THAT NAME
BECAUSE THAT'S LITERALLY THE
NAME HE USED, USED TO THE CROWDS
TAUNTING HIM IS NOW LIVING IN A
VERY DANGEROUS REALITY.
IN THIS DIVISIVE CLIMATE, HE
SAID THE TAUNTS ARE GETTING TOO
REAL AND THE SPORT IS WHO
DANGEROUS FOR HIM.
ELLE REEVE HAS THIS FASCINATING
REPORTING.
♪
>> Reporter: THIS IS POLITICS IN
AMERICA RIGHT NOW.
CHANNELED THROUGH A PRO
WRESTLING RING.
>> I JUST CRITICIZED THEIR WAY
OF LIFE AND TELL THEM HOW THEY
NEED TO FOLLOW A REAL MAN OR MY
HERO JOSEPH R. BIDEN.
>> Reporter: THE PROGRESSIVE JOE
RICHARDSES IS A WRESTLER FANS
LOVE TO HATE.
>> WHEN I GRAB HIM AND THE FANS
SAY HIT HIM IN THE MOUTH, AND
THEY COME FROM THE SEATS, I HIT
HIM IN THE MOUTH.
AND THEY GO, HE DID THAT FOR US.
>> Reporter: AND HIS MENTOR
BEAU-JAMES CAME UP WITH THAT
WHEN TRUMP WAS FIRST PRESIDENT.
>> MY GOODNESS, IF WE HAD A GUY
THAT WAS ANTI-TRUMP AND SEND HIM
TO THE RINGS IN THESE TOWNS, HOW
MUCH HATE WOULD WE GET?
>> THEY WANT TO SEE YOU GET YOUR
ASS KICKED.
THAT'S THE HEAT YOU WANT.
>> IT'S THE GREATEST FEELING IN
THE WORLD.
IT'S A HIGH.
>> Reporter: NOW THAT POLITICS
HAS GOTTEN SO INTENSE, IT'S
GETTING TOO REAL FOR DAN.
>> THE RESPONSE TO ME, AND
PEOPLE WHO THINK LIKE ME ARE
MORE VIOLENT.
>> Reporter: DAN REALLY IS
LIBERAL.
I FIRST INTERVIEWED HIM IN 2017
WHICH NOW BIZARRELY FEELS LIKE A
MORE INNOCENT TIME.
BUT IN 2017, WERE YOU LIKE
ALL-OVER, HILLARY SHIRTS, BEING
HILLARY FOCUSED.
BUT PIECES OF CURRENT EVENTS, DO
YOU PULL FROM, TO SORT OF
TRIGGER PEOPLE?
>> I'VE GOT A BIDEN SHIRT.
ONE OF KAMALA HARRIS.
THE BIDEN ONE TRIGGERS MORE
PEOPLE THAN ANYTHING.
I DON'T THINK HALF OF NIECE
PEOPLE EVEN KNOW WHO KAMALA
HARRIS IS.
>> Reporter: DAN SAYS HE GETS
MORE HEAT NOW THAN WHEN TRUMP
WAS IN OFFICE.
HE FEELS LIKE FANS FEEL LIKE
THEY GOT THEIR HERO TAKEN AWAY.
>> THERE'S SO MANY PEOPLE THAT
THINK THE ELECTION WAS STOLEN.
I SELL REALISM AND EMOTION.
IT GETS EMOTION OUT OF PEOPLE.
WHATEVER THE HEADLINES ARE THAT
WEEK, THAT'S WHAT WE'RE GOING TO
USE.
>> Reporter: DID YOU EVER TALK
ABOUT THE ELECTION BEING STOLEN?
>> YEAH, IF DAN WINS BY
CHEATING, HIS OPPONENT CAN GO TO
THE MICROPHONE LIKE I DO AND
SAY, I LOT OF THESE GOOD PEOPLE
THINK THAT YOU STOLE THAT, JUST
LIKE AN ELECTION WAS STOLE, THE
BUILDING GOES NUTS.
>> Reporter: THEY USUALLY
WRESTLE IN APPALACHIAN COUNTIES
SOME WENT FOR TRUMP BY MORE THAN
80%.
>> IT'S A SMALL MOUNTAIN TIME.
POOR COUNTY, POOR COMMUNITY, NO
HOPE.
HE REPRESENTS TO THEM EVERYTHING
THAT HAS PUT THEM IN THAT
POSITION.
>> Reporter: DO YOU THINK IT'S
CHANGED IN THE LAST FIVE YEARS,
HOW INTENSE IT IS?
>> YAEAH, IT'S MORE DANGEROUS.
>> MOMENT I REALIZE WHEN THINGS
HAVE CHANGED WHEN I HAVE ROCK
STAR ENVY AND SOMEONE TRIES TO
LIGHT ME ON FIRE AND PULL A
KNIFE ON ME.
>> Reporter: SO RECENTLY?
>> YEAH, THAT WAS A MONTH AGO.
>> PEOPLE ARE EVEN MORE FLUFT
TRAITED.
THEY'RE EVEN MORE DIVIDED.
NOW ARE PEOPLE IN OUR TOWN
SAYING THIS STUFF THAT WE SEE ON
TELEVISION THAT WE DON'T AGREE
WITH.
SO, WE CAN'T GET THOSE PEOPLE,
WE CAN'T GET THE POLITICIANS,
LET'S GET HIM.
>>> THE COMMUNITY OF ABOUT 330
PEOPLE.
FANS CAME READY TO BOO DAN.
>> WE HAVE OUR OWN OPINION BUT
HIS, ESPECIALLY IN THIS AREA, IS
A LOT DIFFERENT AND EVERYBODY
WANTS TO PUNCH HIM IN THE FACE.
>> WE LOVE WRESTLING, FIRST OF
ALL, BUT TO SHOW THE LIBERAL,
HEY, WE KNOW WHAT WE STAND FOR.
DEFINITELY LOT THE LEFT SIDE.
>> Reporter: DO YOU WANT TO SEE
HIM GET BEAT UP?
>> YES.
>> Reporter: DO YOU WANT TRUMP
TO RUN AGAIN?
>> AMEN.
>> Reporter: YOU DO?
>> YES.
>> Reporter: CORY WRESTLES AS
WHITE TRASH MILLIONAIRE.
HE DOESN'T LIKE POLITICS BUT
HE'S OFF THE TRUMP TRAIN.
>> I DON'T SEE HOW THINGS CAN
GET WORSE BUT WITH TRUMP WE
WOULD FIND OUT.
>> Reporter: YOU THINK SO?
>> I BELIEVE SO.
WHEN YOU STOP PUTTING AMERICA
FIRST AND START PUTTING YOURSELF
AND WHAT YOU WANT TO DO FIRST.
I'M JUMPING OFF ANY TRAIN.
>> Reporter: TELL ME WHEN THAT
MOMENT WAS.
>> TWITTER.
IF I'M AT MY JOB AND I'M
CONSTANTLY TWEETING, I'M GETTING
FIRED.
I WANT SOMEBODY THAT LEADS THIS
COUNTRY BY ACTIONS NOT BY WORDS.
>> Reporter: THE CROWD WAS LOUD
FOR OTHER MATCHES U BUT WHEN DAN
WALKED OUT IT WAS NEXT LEVEL.
THEN HE GOT OUT OF THE RING AND
RILED THEM UP MORE.
A GUY LOOKD REAED READY TO FIGH.
SOME FANS FOUGHT EACH OTHER.
BEAU CUT THE MATCH SHORT.
BACKSTAGE THEY A SAID THE CROWD
GOT TOO HOT, TOO FAST.
>> WE FELT IT COMING.
WE PUSHED IT TOO FAR.
>> IT'S A DIFFERENT KIND OF HATE
NOW AND IT'S AT A LEVEL I
HAVEN'T EXPERIENCED PREVIOUSLY.
IT'S GETTING MORE VIOLENT AND ON
WHAT SIDE IT'S COMING FROM, HAVE
A REALITY CHECK.
>> YOU HAVE TO KNOW HOW TO HEAR
IT, FEEL IT, LIVE IT.
YOU CAN BE GREAT AND DO ALL THE
ATHLETIC MOVES AND ALL THE
STUFF.
IF YOU DON'T KNOW YOUR AUDIENCE
IT DOESN'T MATTER.
>> I ALWAYS SAY YOU HAVE A WAY
OF JUST DISARMING PEOPLE SO THEY
TELL YOU EXACTLY WHAT THEY ARE
EXPERIENCING AND THINKING.
WHY DID YOU WANT TO TELL US THIS
STORY?
>> I HAD FELT POLITICS BEING
MORE HEATED AND INTENSE WHEN I
COVERED IT.
MAYBE AT A POLITICAL RALLY OR
SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
I WAS LOOKING FOR A WAY THAT
COULD SHOW THIS VISUALLY.
HOW INTENSE IT WAS EVEN FOR THE
AVERAGE PERSON.
SO I CALLED UP DAN AND BEAU.
>> WHAT WAS IT LIKE BEING ON THE
GROUND THERE AS YOU'RE REPORTING
THIS OUT AND LISTENING TO
STORIES.
IT'S AN INTERESTING PERSPECTIVE.
>> THE WRESTLERS OFTEN HAVE SO
MUCH KNOWLEDGE AND WINZ DOM
ABOUT WHAT REGULAR PEOPLE WANT
TO HEAR AND FEELING AND THEIR
FRUSTRATIONS.
I LOVE THAT.
IT WAS ONE OF THE NICEST
SUPPORTING CROWDS BECAUSE THE
ANNOUNCERS CAME ON SAYING THESE
GIRLS ARE NICE AND LOVE
WRESTLING SO BE NICE TO THEM.
>> THAT'S NOT ALWAYS THE
RECEPTION YOU GT AT OTHER TRUMP'
VENTS.
IT'S A PERSPECTIVE IN A WORLD
VIEW OF PEOPLE THAT YOU DON'T
ALWAYS GET TALKING TO LAWMAKERS.
>> THEY ARE THERE.
IT'S UNPOLISHED AND THEY ARE
ACTUALLY -- THERE'S NO MEDIA
PROFESSIONAL TWEAKING EVERY WORD
THEY SAY.
IT'S VERY REAL.
>> HOW DO I SAY THIS WITHOUT --
THAT MADE MY SAD.
THEY CAN'T TELL THE DIFFERENCE,
IN MY WAY, I'M GENERALIZING
BETWEEN REALITY AND NOT REALITY.
THIS IS SOMETHING THAT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE FUN.
THEY ARE OPERATING ON THIS WHOLE
THING ABOUT PEOPLE, THE
DEMOCRATS BEING EVIL AND
ELECTION DENIAL AND THE ELECTION
WAS STOLEN AND ALL THAT.
IT JUST MAKES ME REALLY SAD.
I WANT TO SAY HEY, GUYS.
NONE OF WHAT YOU'RE BELIEVING IS
TRUE.
I DON'T KNOW.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO WITH
THAT.
I REALLY DON'T.
>> I THINK IT DOES REFLECT THE
DEHUMANIZATION OF YOUR POLITICAL
OPPONENTS THAT WE'RE SEEING NOW.
WHEN I INTERVIEWED THEM FIVE
YEARS AGO, I INTERVIEWED PEOPLE
IN THE CROWD AND THEY WERE
LAUGHING.
THEY WOULD BE LIKE WHO DOESN'T
LOVE THE HATE THE LIBERAL.
NOW IT'S WAY MORE SERIOUS.
>> AS WE HAVE SEEN AROUND THE
COUNTRY --
>> DANGEROUS.
THAT'S WHY I SAID I DON'T KNOW
WHAT TO DO WITH THAT.
WE ARE AT POINT NOW WITH PEOPLE
BEING WHO THEY ARE, BECAUSE OF
WHAT THEY BELIEVE, THEY ARE IN
DANGER.
As WE SEE, FIVE PEOPLE ARE DEAD
IN LARGE PART BECAUSE OF NOT
BELIEVING OR VILIFYING PEOPLE
THEY DON'T AGREE WITH.
THANK YOU.
I APPRECIATE IT.
>> THANK YOU VERY MUCH.